good morning if everyone would like to
take their seats we'll get started
good morning to all of you once again we
have a gorgeous day um and I am really
thankful for that we have a plan if
there's ever foul weather and we're very
hopeful that we never have to use that
plan it's much nicer to do it out
here so family survivors Governor sonunu
New Hampshire attorney general Fela
fellow officers
distinguished guests and Friends good
morning my name is Kevin Jordan and I am
the chief of the law enforcement
division at New Hampshire fishing game
and it's also my distinct personal honor
to serve as the president of the New
Hampshire Law Enforcement Officers
Memorial Association on behalf of this
Association I would like to welcome you
all to the 32nd annual law enforcement
New Hampshire Law Enforcement Officers
Memorial ceremony I would now ask you
all to please stand for the opening
procession and the present of colors to
begin our Memorial
[Music]
ceremony e
for
[Music]
h
[Applause]
[Music]
details fre
detail now who
on
over
go
[Music]
time
fil from the left
ping Squad all C
sad
he
please remain standing for the singing
of our national anthem this year I would
like to introduce you all to the marac
Valley High School vocal Ensemble which
has agreed to come join us today and
sing for us
Allard fre
[Music]
the light what so proudly
we at the
twlight last gleaming who brought
stripes and bright stars through the
per fight or the r parts
was were so
gently
streaming and the rocket
redare the bombs
bursting in air gave Pro through the
night that our flag was still
there oh say does that star
spangled bner yet
W for the
land of the
free and the
home of
the of the Brave
[Applause]
please be seated for the reading of the
Old Glory poem presented today by
Sergeant Craig Emery of the Marat County
Department of Corrections
coloni
hoay good
morning I am the flag of the United
States of America my name is Old Glory I
fly at top the world's tallest buildings
I stand watch in America's Halls of
Justice I fly majestically over great
Institutes of
learning I stand guard with the greatest
military power in the
world look up and see me I Stand For
Peace honor truth and
Justice I Stand For
Freedom when I am flown with my fellow
banners my head is a little higher my
colors a little truer and I bow to no
one
I recognized all over the world I am
woried I am saluted I am respected I am
loved and I am
feared I F I fly in silent watch over
the courageous men and women of law
enforcement as they protect and serve as
the Guardians of our
communities I have fought every battle
of every war for more than 200 years
Gettysburg Shiloh San Juan Hill The
Trenches of France the Argon Forest
anzio Rome the beaches of Normandy the
deserts of Africa the cane fields of the
Philippines the rice patties and jungles
of Guam okanawa Japan Korea Vietnam and
a score of places long forgotten by all
but those who were there with me I was
there I led my soldiers
I followed them I watched over them they
loved me as on a small hill in uima I
was dirty battle Warn and tired but my
Marines cheered me and I was
proud I have been soiled burned torn and
trampled on the streets of countries
that I have helped to set free it does
not hurt for I'm
Invincible I've been soiled burned torn
and trampled on the streets of my own
country and when it is by those with
whom I've served in battle it hurts but
I shall overcome for I am
strong I have slipped the bonds of Earth
and stand watch over the New Frontiers
of space from my vantage point on the
moon I have been a Silent Witness to all
of America's Finest
Hours but my finest Hour comes when I'm
torn into strips to be used for bandages
for my wounded comrades in the field of
battle when I fly at half Mass to honor
my soldiers and when I lie in the
trembling arms of a grieving loved one
at the
gravide of a fallen son daughter sister
brother or friend I am
proud my name is Old Glory long may I W
wave dear God long may I wave
we are once again very fortunate to have
chaplain Gerald gonsalo chaplain of the
lerer police department here with us
this morning I would now ask you to
please stand and give your attention to
chaplain gono as he offers our opening
prayer
thank let us pray
Lord it is with great reverence That We
Gather here today with family friends
and fellow Law Enforcement Officers to
remember our
fallen their dedication devotion and
sacrifice will never be forgotten by
Those whom they served with the
community or their loved
ones as a nation and as Granite Staters
we take this time each year to honor
those who have given their lives in the
line of Duty as a
memorial however for those who have
personally experienced the loss our
fallen are remembered every day may we
never forget that our fallen are more
than just Law Enforcement Officers they
are Sons and Daughters husbands and
wives mothers and fathers and best
friends their sacrifice has left an
indelible mark on those who Lov them and
Those whom they served
we must never forget that there is no
routine day for law enforcement officers
their sacrifice is embodied in the words
of Our Lord in the Gospel of John
greater love has no one than this than
to lay down one's life for his
friends Lord in remembrance of their
sacrifice today we ask your blessing and
your presence upon this service and all
those here in Jesus name we pray amen
everyone can be
seated family survivors Governor sonunu
New Hampshire Attorney General John
fella United States Attorney Jane young
fellow Law Enforcement Officers Senator
Hass
Senator Shaheen Congressman Annie kuster
Congressman Chris papis Senate President
Jeb Bradley and Speaker of our house
Sherman Packard and distinguished guests
thank you for participating in the 32nd
annual New Hampshire law enforcement
memorial ceremony Governor sonunu is
designated today as the New Hampshire
Law Enforcement Officers Memorial Day a
day for us to pause and to reflect on
the contributions of all law enforcement
officers governor sonuna was also
ordered that our New Hampshire state
flag all of our flags to fly at half
staff throughout this day in remembrance
of those fallen heroes who are honored
on our memorial wall Governor sonunu is
the 82nd and current governor of the
state of New Hampshire he was elected as
governor in 2016 and sworn into his
office on January 5th of
2017 currently serving in his fourth
term Governor sonunu has worked to
maintain New Hampshire's high quality of
life as one of the safest and most
livable states in the nation we live in
ever more dangerous times and it is
comforting to know that we have a
governor who is committed to support and
who has shown great respect to all law
enforcement and First Responders along
with their families in our state we all
recognize and respect the ultimate
sacrifices these officers inscribed on
this beautiful Monument behind me made
for the safety of all of our New
Hampshire citizens it is just as
important for all of us to recognize and
respect the unimaginable sacrifice
of the families and the friends of these
Brave officers that were made and
endured by all of you survivors I am
very confident when I tell you that
Governor sununu does recognize and
respect that sacrifice he fully
understands you have suffered tremendous
losses and he has committed to the
health and well-being of our citizens
the safety of our communities and all
First Responders in the future of our
state Governor sonunu has graci
graciously accepted our invitation to
provide our keynote address at our 32nd
annual ual ceremony and ladies and
gentlemen is my honor to present to you
the governor of the state of New
Hampshire his Excellency Governor Chris
sonunu well good morning it is great to
see everybody out here uh as the colonel
mentioned earlier uh we are just
continually blessed with great weather
uh and and it really does make a
difference it allows a lot of a lot of
folks to come out you know I also want
to note you know I love that we do this
event here here we do a variety of
events all across the state for various
reasons but um the fact that we always
kind of do it here this is obviously
where the memorial is uh we have
students that might be visiting on a
field trip we have uh law enforcement
from a variety of different agencies
that come and as this is my I guess
seventh technically eighth time uh doing
this um I'm getting to know a lot of you
I mean a lot of these families that have
made really this sacrifice and not made
a sacrifice but as the colonel mentioned
continuously make that sacrifice
continuously live um with that with the
burdens the struggles knowing that you
may have lost a loved one but done so um
in the line of of saving someone else in
the line of going out there every day
putting everything on the line and
having individuals that are willing to
do that uh often without question
without hesitation uh it really is
awesome it is um so obviously thank you
for for being here it's a beautiful day
but it is a solemn day right it is a day
of of remembrance for a lot of
individuals a lot of families
so to all the members of law enforcement
obviously we always want to begin by
thanking you for your service everyone
has a choice um there's no draft into
law enforcement these are men and women
and individuals who said I want to
protect my community in one way or the
other and there's a variety of different
ways to serve in law enforcement but
every single one of these individuals
does their does it of their own valtion
of their own accord uh and chooses to to
you know stand a post and say what can I
do to make everybody's else's lives
safer and that takes commitment and it
takes sacrifice and as we me have
mentioned and we'll continue to mention
not just sacrifice of those individuals
but of those families who also carry
that every single
day so this year we're we pay tribute to
uh once again 55 55 individuals in their
families and I guess it is a blessing to
say that this year is one of the few
years thank God that we are not adding
any new names to the memorial it should
bring us all an incredible amount
um of Pride to know that our law
enforcement is out there every day
devoted to protecting and serving our
communities and they they truly are the
best in the
nation as we have much to pray um and
plan on let's understand first and
foremost no state is immune as amazing
as these individuals are no state is
immune from tragedy can strike anywhere
at any time uh you can pass all the laws
in the world put all the bubble wrap
around the system that you want but at
the end end of the day tragedy can
strike in a lot of different forms in a
lot of different
ways what constantly reassures me and
what allows all of us I think to sleep
well at night is knowing that when
tragedy might strike our communities our
Law Enforcement Officers run into the
danger without hesitation only thinking
of the job at hand in speaking with them
often after such events you hear that
the only thing on their mind in those
moments was the safety of others they
don't come to you and say well the first
thing I thought of is what do I have to
do to Duck and Cover that's not what you
hear ever literally ever it's always
about how do we get in there how do we
provide provide protection to those that
are that are under
harm that unflinching response is
because they know that the safeties of
others truly depends on them hearing
those stories it makes you want to step
back and really see the bigger picture
and it does it reminds us I think all of
what is truly important making sure our
priorities are straight and we often
gather right here in conquer to tout new
successes and we have a lot to be proud
of we could be here all day talking
about that but if there's one thing that
I've learned to be true it's no matter
again what policies are passed in these
buildings no matter what the debate is
that may play out in these halls or the
coverage that you see on TV it is the
people on the front lines that really
matter New Hampshire is proudly the
number one state for Public Safety and
proudly ranked as one of the best states
uh in the country to live in number one
overall in the east as we like to to
brag about and but that is all thanks to
work done by our our law enforcement
each and every member of our law
enforcement is gathered here today and
being represented and every single name
that adorns this Memorial here is an
individual to thank those of you who
attend this ceremony each year know that
I always remind everyone that just as
the sacrifice made by these officers is
not just it's not just one day this
isn't just a one day memorial event it
is really something that I truly believe
I think we all believe we need to carry
with us 365 days a year right and when
again I kind of look at the the kids
here I have my own kids a lot of you are
here with your families representing
your families maybe you've lost a loved
one maybe you're just coming out of the
office to to gather with us today at the
memorial but it's about carrying that
that understanding of that sacrifice and
what that means to all of these families
and carrying that with us day in and day
out instilling something new with our
kids the lessons to be learned the honor
the pride that it is to serve um and the
opportunity it is to do something
for your community something that can
leave a a truly indel indelible Mark and
strengthens our communities not because
of politicians and not because of
policies they're always strengthened by
the individuals that are standing up and
making a difference and it's no easy
burden the state of New Hampshire is
proud to stand with all these families
and we obviously thank you for your
courage your sacrifice um continuing to
carry that burden New Hampshire is many
things but first and foremost we are
just that neighbors and community that
is truly how we Define ourselves Live
Free or Die it's about the individual
it's not about a big system and to have
individual standing up for each other
any given day under any circumstance no
matter what that tragedy may bring um
it's in in the good weather or bad
they're always there for us and it
really is something that allows us I
think a lot of Solace to sleep on so as
I Look To The Future my time in office
does grow shorter um I think the focus
always has to be on ensuring the
successes that we've made aren't just
temporary right they have to be long
lasting we want them to to truly take
root this is this very Memorial That We
Gather in front of today it was designed
with the vision of the Eternal Shield
resting upon New Hampshire's Granite the
Eternal Flame at top the monument
reminds us that the that the light of
Peace the protection that brought us to
to that brought us the brave souls that
it does memorialize that protection and
that flame does live on for eternity and
we have to never forget that so thank
you all may God bless you all your
families and this great state thank
[Applause]
you thank you Governor
sonunu the New Hampshire Police
Association pipes and drums have been
performing musical selections for the
memorial service Faithfully for more
than two decades now in fact the band's
first public event was this very
Memorial ceremony back in
1996 the New Hampshire Police
Association pipes and drums was formed
following the tragic line of duty death
of New Hampshire State Police Sergeant
James noise in
1994 since this time this band has
played at every police officer line of
death Duty a lineup Duty death excuse me
funeral in New Hampshire it is now my
great pleasure to introduce to all of
you the New Hampshire Police Association
pipes and
drums for
[Music]
is
for
it's an amazing band we're very very
grateful that they take time every year
to join us here at the
ceremony uh to my fellow uh officer
seated to my right over here I want to
apologize for the placement of those
chairs it didn't fall on deaf ears that
those chairs are too close together and
we'll fix that for next year I my
apologies I also saw a k9 in that band
and we will have a dog bed included in
those chairs next year because she is
not going to sit on the hot pavement
during a
ceremony it is my personal honor to
represent the memorial Association as
the Master of Ceremonies for today's
service the New Hampshire law
enforcement memorial Association is made
up of a small group of very dedicated
and hardworking individuals who work
throughout the year to preserve and
honor this beauti Memorial behind me and
to ensure that the family and friends of
all of our fallen heroes understand and
believe that New Hampshire law
enforcement Community will never forget
the sacrifice these officers and their
families have made today is the one day
of the year where we invite the public
to join us in Remembering and honoring
those sacrifices made by these law
enforcement officers who died in the
line of duty we must also reflect on the
contributions of all our living law
enforcement officers and pray for the
continued safety each and every day
I would also be remiss if I didn't
mention the brave contributions of all
the fire and emergency medical
responders who continue their commitment
and sacrifice to serve the citizens of
the State of New Hampshire who place
their lives on the line each day today
we honor as Heroes the 55 New Hampshire
Law Enforcement Officers whose names
appear on the New Hampshire law
enforcement memorial wall on this day I
would also like to take a moment to
recognize someone who was instrumental
in the creation of this beautiful
monument that stands behind me
approximately 30 years ago the original
Law Enforcement Officers Memorial
committee was working very hard in an
effort to raise adequate funds to create
a permanent Memorial to honor our fallen
heroes when they finally achieved their
fundraising goals they asked a Committee
Member at the time a man by the name of
Van McLoud a former director of the
Council of the Arts to arrange for some
artists to submit proposals or models of
a concept of what this Memorial would
look like and to present those IDE ideas
to all the committee retired New
Hampshire fishing game major Tim Aero a
good friend of mine who's still on the
on the committee today one of the
original members of this committee
shared his memories of this process
major asero stated to me that this was
just a room full of cops that really
knew very little about real art Mr
McLoud brought the committee four or
five proposals from various artists and
after a brief discussion they made the
decision to ask an artist by the name of
Emil Burch Emil's creative Spirit was
one of a true artist he shared his work
through the the New Hampshire State
Council on the Arts teaching through the
artist in Residence program within the
schools hospitals and training centers
for people with physical Andor emotional
challenges beginning in
1976 some of you may have heard over the
years what each part of this morial
Memorial represents to AAL the overall
shape is a star for a reason as ail
would point out to us we all wore Badges
of various shapes and colors but to him
the first badge was one he felt was most
associated with and represents law
enforcement and that was a star the
flame in the center represents the
internal flame of Hope and he felt this
flame was also symbolic of the memory of
the law enforcement officers that would
be inscribed on it every law enforcement
agency in the state donated a badge from
their prospective departments I am told
and those badges are Buried buried in
the ground below the center tower under
the flame this Memorial was designed to
attract people to come inside to
investigate to sit down and reflect on
the sacrifices of each of the officers
inscribed on the wall and while seated
inside they would also be shielded a bit
from the hustle and bustle of the
outside
world Emil also oversaw All Phases of
the construction onsite for absolutely
every step from beginning to end I am
told Emil would probably be mortified
that we're here today recognizing him
for designing and building this Memorial
he did this not for the recognition but
because he wanted to share his talents
and love for the Arts and he wanted to
honor our New Hampshire Heroes Emil
Burch lived in Canan New Hampshire and
we lost ail last year at the age of 76
on November 9th
2023 to Amil and his surviving family we
are all forever grateful for your
efforts your commitment and your
extraordinary talent in creating this
law enforcement memorial to honor all of
our New Hampshire law enforcement
Heroes before we proceed with the
ceremony we want to express our
appreciation to all of those who have
made this day possible on the inside
cover of the 2024 program is a list of
people and organizations that have all
gener generously made Financial
contributions or have provided equipment
or skills that all serve to make this
ceremony possible we would like to
acknowledge all of their generosity and
their support I also would like to give
a shout out to Manchester Police
Department on the cover of your program
this year is a mounted Manchester police
officer our Honor Guard today our high
honor guard today that stands to my left
is Manchester police Manchester police
has always been very active in this
Memorial they have officers on the wall
and I just want to thank them for their
continued
participation most importantly we would
like thank
you most importantly we would like to
acknowledge all of you who attended
today along with each Survivor of our
fallen heroes listed on this wall we
would also like to thank everyone for
your continued assistance and
contributions to the memorial and
Perpetual care fund without your
generous donations we would not be here
today to honor our fallen
heroes Chief osgard and chief Goldstein
uh will come up now and position our
flowers so that we can begin the most
solemn part of our
ceremony for
now comes the most solemn moment that
culminates today's program the reading
of the role of honor and the placing of
flowers on the memorial wreath as the
names are read a member of the family if
present should stand walk towards the
center aisle an escorting officer will
come to your location and lead you to
the floral display down the center aisle
there you will be given a flower by
these two good-looking young men Josh
and Zach to add to the wreath and memory
of your loved one for those family
members who are unable to attend today
or for those who are no longer have
living relatives an officer from that
department or another department will
step forward and place a flower on the
wreath I would then ask you to return to
your seats by either of the end aisles
after a flower is placed for each of the
55 officers inscribed uh in our Memorial
nine additional flowers will be placed
in an effort to recognize and honor some
special categories of
people those of us working in law
enforcement in the State of New
Hampshire today serve under the
direction of the New Hampshire Attorney
General New Hampshire's Attorney General
John Fela was nominated by governor
sonunu and subsequently confirmed by our
executive council members attorney
general Fela was then sworn into the
office on April 22nd
20121 and he now leads the New Hampshire
Department of just of justice as the
chief law enforcement official and
prosecutor in the state attorney famela
has a very distinguished law career in
New Hampshire he has served as the legal
counc to the governor on all significant
legal issues and litigation affecting
the state of New Hampshire uh his legal
expertise and experience played a
significant role in the development and
implementation of New Hampshire's
Criminal Justice Reform initiatives and
attorney general famela came to us here
in New Hampshire as a gifted attorney
who was highly principled and committed
to always doing the right thing to the
highest professional standard New
Hampshire is extremely fortunate to have
such a knowledgeable and dedicated
Attorney General serving as the chief
law enforcement for the citizens of the
State of New Hampshire it is now my
honor and privilege to introduce to you
the New Hampshire Attorney General John
formela and ask him to join me at the
podium to read the role of
Honor deput Sheriff John S Walker senior
chesher County Sheriff's Department
officer George E prey do police
department
officer Charles H dolliff Laconia Police
Department
deputy sheriff Charles E Smith straford
County Sheriff's Department
Sergeant Henry mallister Manchester
Police Department
patrolman Frank J Dustin Manchester
inspector William M mower Manchester
Police Department
assistant Marshall John mcdna do police
department
officer Albert L Coulson exiter Police
Department
Officer James roach NASA police
department
Sheriff Harry M levit Carrol County
Sheriff's Department
Trooper Raymond Elliott New Hampshire
State Police
Chief Andrew T Malloy Lancaster Police
Department
Trooper Harold B Johnson New Hampshire
State Police
Chief Fred T tol colbrook Police
Department
officer Michael latvis Nashua Police
Lieutenant Ivan H Hayes New Hampshire
State Police
corrections officer George F Garo
Hillsboro County Corrections
officer Joseph H Platt North umberland
Police Department
officer Edward C Graziano nasua Police
Department conservation Officer William
O money New Hampshire Fish and Game
department conservation officer Gary e
Waterhouse New Hampshire Fish and Game
department assistant Chief Lewis a
sheets Farmington Police Department
officer Robert F devoid Berlin Police
Department
officer Dorman o Wheelock bur Berlin
Police
Department off officer Jerome o Patt
gorum Police
Department corrections officer Robert C
Prescott Rockingham County Department of
Corrections conservation officer James H
Clark New Hampshire Fish and Game
department
Chief Armen J rousel NASA police
Chief Charles SB nolles seab Brook
Police Department
Lieutenant Robert Hollis Jr Durham
Sergeant Paul G broer Berlin Police
Department
officer Ralph W Miller Manchester Police
[Music]
Trooper Richard F champy New Hampshire
State Police
officer Donal Donald R Kowalski
summersworth Police Department
supervisor William E O'Neal
senior Jaffrey Police
Department chief James H Collins
Handover Police Department
Sergeant Thomas C Kelly Dairy Police
Department
Trooper Gary Parker New Hampshire State
Police
Trooper Joseph E Gertie New Hampshire
State Police
Chief Ralph C Brooks antrum Police
Department
dep Sheriff Donald E Callahan Marram
County Sheriff's Department
Sergeant James S noise New Hampshire
State Police
officer Melvin a ky East Kingston Police
Department
Lieutenant Donald Eaton Auburn Police
Trooper Leslie G Lord New Hampshire
State Police
Trooper Scott Phillips New Hampshire
officer Jeremy T Sharon Epsom Police
Department
officer Michael L Briggs Manchester
Police Department
Corporal n Bruce McKay III Franconia
Chief Michael P Maloney Greenland Police
Department
officer Stephen J arel Brentwood Police
staff sergeant Jesse E Cheryl New
Hampshire State Police
officer Rory L Bohanan Hillsboro Police
Department
corrections officer Lawrence C Prather
New Hampshire Department of Corrections
one flower will be placed in recog
recognition of all family survivors
one flower will be placed to honor all
officers who died outside the line of
duty
one flower will be placed to honor New
Hampshire law enforcement officers who
died in the line of duty outside of the
State of New Hampshire
one flower will be placed in recognition
of all of our service members serving
around the world who continue to fight
so bravely and who have sacrificed their
lives in an effort to protect our
precious freedoms
one flower will be placed in recognition
of the daily sacrif
of all living
officers one flower will be placed in
recognition of those officers injured in
the line of duty
one flower will be placed in recognition
of our courageous K9 Partners serving
throughout the state alongside New
Hampshire law enforcement officers
one flower will be placed to honor all
New Hampshire active duty Federal
officers who have lost their lives
and one flower will be placed in
recognition of all retired New Hampshire
law enforcement officers who have lost
their lives lives
than
he
and for
h
[Music]
for
perial
please remain standing while the marac
Valley High School chorus Ensemble again
joins us up here at the podium for our
closing
hymn e
beautiful for
spous
for waves of
GRA po Purple
Mountain
mes above the fruit
[Music]
[Applause]
am God shed his grace on
the and C th good with
Brotherhood from sea to shining
SE oh beautiful
for p dream that sees beond the
years
th
C by human
te
Amer God shed his grace on the
and Crown th good with
Brotherhood from sea to
shining sea
[Applause]
please put you put us on your calendar
for next year you
guys I'd like to now ask uh chaplain
gonsalo to join us again for God's
blessings let us
pray as we close this ceremony Lord we
ask that you comfort the families
friends and comrades of our fallen
officers
we remain grateful for our men and W
women who Dawn the
uniform each day to protect and serve
and we ask that you watch over them as
they do so may you grant them wisdom and
discernment and bless the work of their
hands and as we depart may offer this
final blessing may the Lord bless you
and keep you the Lord make his face
shine upon you and be gracious to you
the Lord lift up his countenance upon
you and give you peace peace
amen Chief if you want to move that
those flowers back up on the sidewalk
for us
once again this year the memorial
committee has designed and created law
enforcement memorial shirts challenge
coins Memorial lapel pins and
registration uh decals for number plates
these items are all developed to honor
each officer and all proceeds from the
sales of these items uh utilized in the
upkeep and maintenance of our Memorial
uh as well as supporting this annual
ceremony if you are interested making a
financial contribution or purchasing any
one of these items please see a
Committee Member in the reception area
the law enforcement easy up over to my
left or in the lunch and re reception
after today's ceremony and I would also
like to extend an invitation to each and
every one of you to join us for a light
luncheon being provided at the conquered
Community Center located right up the
street here on Green Street up beside
the conquered Police
Department as in the past I want to
leave everyone with one final
thought please remember that poor is the
nation that has no Heroes shameful is
the nation that has Heroes and forgets
thank you for joining us today to honor
our New Hampshire law enforcement
officer fallen heroes and I will now ask
the New Hampshire motor units followed
by The Police Association pipes and
drums to lead the honor guards in
retreat for
[Music]
w oh
call
heart
we want to thank you all for coming
today that this concludes our service
for today thank you